I'll give you everything I [__] have
every [__] secret that pops into my
Dome every tactic that I've got every
connection I can give you every hello I
can give you every acknowledgment I can
give you my three seconds attention when
we run into each other at an airport
answer you when I can give you the best
content that I can give you the
blueprint that got me here when I can
produce invest in production of content
at scale try to [__] extract
everything that's in my [__] soul for
you for free like I want to be the great
entrepreneur of this generation there'll
be people who make more money than me
there'll be people that invent more but
nobody's gonna give a [__] about Their
audience more